what an exciting day for all of you but
really her I was the original emoji meet
smiler there is nothing like getting
scammed for the first time it gives your
all of it really she's more than a
pretty place I will never ever make a
mistake yet only nothing whoa dude we
know you whoa the first time you said it
it's not a genuine but then you repeated
it and then that that was weird
all right good talk the emoji movie July
28 look cool just the music Maddy
McCallister what should I say just play
it cool
welcome to the world inside your phone
where everyone is expected to act one
way their whole life how my machine and
I'm supposed to be a man max who cares
my problem is I have more than one
emotion like this out huh God please
tell me you weren't laughing just now
what if you get sent out on the phone
making the wrong face and I'll make the
right face then I would finally fit in
created you're so handsome when you make
that face I think he's ready now
SAP our user Alan we have an incoming
text we are go for meth me oh wait he's
making the wrong thing hmm huh what the
heck
welcome to the loser lounge where the
emojis you never get used hangout what's
up Papa I'm an emoji a guy half done
sort of purpose here I'm gonna help you
we need to get off the phone and find
the source code then I can fit in that's
bro
my Felicia first we have to get through
this firewall smell is this girlfriend's
name again it was Tina can I carry Sarah
I want to say Lupita
but that doesn't feel right now I'm
saying out loud I think you're pretty
cool to say why
[Music]
my feelings are huge maybe any men have
more than just one of us here am i candy
crush
goodbye I'll never eat another piece of
candy ever again huh high-five don't do
it don't you do it it's already been in
there once okay son what do we do after
we go potty should we wash our hands
you